bonsoir l'inao brahim merci d'être avec
nous un mot tout d'abord sur la mise en
place d'un forfait petit pour les
enfants une vraie bonne nouvelle en
selon la société française de pédiatrie
ou un pansement sur une jambe de bois
selon vous on soit remercie mme
accueillir ce soir
effectivement c'est une bonne façon et
pour agir il ya urgence on a tous
compris aujourd'hui il faut agir mais
intense mais en revanche il pourra agir
en prenant en compte notre expérience
donc bloqué on a les résultats d'études
scientifiques sur le confinement le
premier compliment mais voilà j'ai en
conséquence avec cette connaissance là
mais aussi avec l'expérience
les premières mesures ils sont arrivés
en nombre de chèques
j'ai aussi qui a montré ce que tous les
étudiants qui a montré ses limites
notamment en une proposition qui est
faite sans vraiment de concertation avec
les professionnels de la santé
nous les psychologues et encore une fois
cette position il faut que les psys donc
si j'ai bien compris lycéens se rendit
c'est à 106 ans encore une fois avec la
province militants façon par la
conversion est donc effectivement il
s'agit d'accueillir la souffrance de
passer une chance vous donnez disney ans
et moi ça effectivement
mais ça veut dire passer par la
compassion médecin quel médecin
parfois c'est ce que la semaine que tout
à fait compris qu est ce que j'ai vécu
avec eux c'est l'histoire de chelsea
voilà comment ça se passera avec pepsi
mais encore une fois on essaie de dire
qu'il faut régler tout en lisant ce nom
car je pense que ça va poser une limite
pas à cette question de l'approbation de
l'upci fait de dire c'est ce que je
comprends et beaucoup de koné aussi
beaucoup de plaies
c'est au médecin d'évaluer si la
personne d'enfants ou d'adolescents un
besoin de suivi psychologique
c'est en tout cas ce chèque concernés
les 7 à 10
étant vous l'avez constaté vous dans
votre cabinet avec votre vos patients
c'est un réel besoin il y a beaucoup de
troupes chez ses enfants même jeune il
ya moins de résidence qu'on pouvait
peut-être l'imaginer oui exactement
deuxième avec la fermeture des écoles
c'est encore encore moins de contacts
sociaux déjà il y avait les activités
sportives qui était limitée par un me
disais ça c'était une crainte pour les
activités extrascolaires et maintenant
l'école donc effectivement c'est encore
plus de contacts sociaux privés dont ses
parents
donc oui forcément là je pense qu'on
arrive à les crises
cette tranche d'âge qui démontre des des
symptômes de fil blanc cieux et ça va
jusqu'à la tentative de suicide
c'est bien fait des très jeunes
allaitantes attaque d'inciter l'âge bien
sûr des enfants et adolescents
on trouve chez les adolescents on vend
des problématiques on ait rencontré une
plante et d'éviter ce cyber sas et on va
dire plutôt commun dans les services on
a connaissez toutes les sauces permet
aujourd'hui la différence de temps
peut-être aussi du passage à l'acte ça
te fabien bouard en fait quelqu'un de
quoi souffre le plus c'est ses enfants
fait d'allemand et bien un peu comme les
adultes un peu comme toute la population
aujourd'hui de la limitation des liens
sociaux
après il ya aussi une autre dimension
c'est on va parler de ceux qui ont des
contextes très difficile à la maison et
contextes familiaux très difficile
l'école où les activités préscolaires
constituer une pause pour eux
aujourd'hui à vue cette pause et sont
constamment dans des contextes familiaux
difficiles
je voudrais aussi d'une autre chose
parce que je travaille aussi dans mon
établissement
autour d'eux des personnes en situation
de handicap
ils ce sont des adolescents la
récurrence avec un autisme par exemple
j'en prends cette situation là
les établissements ils ferment quand il
y avait des cas de contact
tant qu'il ya des contacts mais aussi
les jeunes qui ou qui ont contracté le
virus sur le variant d'ailleurs
compliqué en ce moment beaucoup on faire
et enfin le jour au lendemain donc c'est
laisser des familles jean lendemain
s'occuper de leurs jeunes avec la
concurrence à un autisme des affaires
qui brûleront développement personnel et
ce sont des familles qui vont m'appeler
me dire voilà aujourd'hui on lui a dit
qu'il ya des parts qui n'allait pas au
centre et du coup il a développé des
trucs des départements parce qu'il ne
comprend pas puisque dans la déficience
intellectuelle ou encore dans le pti sme
on sait que pour beaucoup d'entre eux il
est question ils sont très attachés à
une team est très difficile pour eux
d'appréhender un changement on parle de
cl 6-1 voulue par le gouvernement
c'est un c'est un exploit un espoir pour
vous une sorte de ségur pour le mental
des des français est ce que c'est encore
un effet d'annoncé où il y aura vraiment
voient là un progrès après ça j'ai pas
qu'on n'est pas bien de toutes les
familles des vidéos pour le mental des
des français en effet soulevé par le
gouvernement tel est votre réaction
lui bien sûr alors c'est un espoir tout
comme on est en ce moment et porter une
proposition pour la création d'un
indécis alors de faire le lien avec ma
profession mais parce que j'espère en
tout cas que se réguler toutes ces
propositions vont être liés à notre
profession et vous en janvier ce sont
c'est à dire nous mettre dans le débat
me placer dans le débat qu'on soit aussi
l'acteur de tous ces débats toutes les
mesures n'a qui ont été prises en compte
que ce soit chelsea ou encore
aujourd'hui le temps philippe si nous
les people salt est mince et mesure à
elle arrive elle nous arrive pas direct
qui nous arrive à travers les médias
monde est content un pop-up statim de la
mort et on doit après chercher comment
mettre en place toutes ces choses là oui
j'ai de l'espoir si vraiment on met tous
les acteurs du départ cours de ce mois
autour d'une table pour débattre de tout
ça et voilà m en train de pêcher
ensemble réfléchir ensemble des choses
merci brahima docteur en psychologie
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france